[Music]
that's a nice dress thank you I like
your jacket
Thanks flights on time
it is great I'm sorry what was that what
you just took a step forward there again
yeah you did you know you did and if
what's funny is there's no way you can
board first because the only way the
board for us is to be a special need do
you have a special need yes I need to be
over there I'm going to the destination
wedding myself tell me experiment so
we're just the people you don't know how
to stick you might as well just stick us
together I don't want to be a person you
don't know where to stick destination
but is presumptuous there in a fool's
paradise you believe there's someone for
everyone close I believe that there's
nobody for anyone
I understand how even after Keith did
what he did to you can possibly still be
mooning over because you're a monkey who
doesn't understand the human condition
having met you I understand why it's a
condition
you know I'm not wearing anything or my
pajamas why would you they're so
alluring
[Music]
what is that think it's a mountain lion
could it be a Jaguar what difference
does it make mm-hmm the Cougar maybe
Jesus Christ
how do you not install a pathway if
tails won't make it can you carry me
please
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you